avant de parler d'amour avec sacha
distel
je voudrais que l'on écoute un grand
artiste qui vient pour la première fois
dans double jeu quelqu'un dont nous
apprécions les prises de position si
courageuse sur la couche d'ozone le
racisme le sida la guerre je veux parler
de patrick webb
je me suis à
acheter un
[Applaudissements]
et je ne me
le soir je me balade avec mon désespoir
mais bon
toi
aucune fille
[Musique]
et
car je ne suis pas
après
non non non
je ne suis
paris
han han
je fais souvent à la
[Musique]
m
c'est sur les gens
pas
l'assiette de risotto
mais
ils me disent chao toutes les filles
[Musique]
car je ne suis pas
m
non
je
ap
estos
entremont
je suis
elle et moi
la première toile en double jeu mesdames
messieurs c'était patrick bruel
non
ce que j'ai dit je suis pas patrick
bruel si enfin patrimoine les
corrections de ne rien rater de 1h10
tube abonnez vous mettez un pouce bleus